[Music]  I got a big hike plan for us tomorrow  can we just do some fun indoor  activities yeah like uh drinking  is this still even a trail wow  how far down do you think that goes  excuse me the Crepes let's go  rise and shine sleepyheads where do the  kids go they're carry on far I'm still  trying to understand how you let them  out of yourself when we woke up they  were gone  guys  there you are no no no stop no  Christ  hey Ben look at me whoa hey hey  you good man  how you been feeling lately I know what  I saw  can I show you something in the woods  I don't think that's them out there  anymore I promise we're better than ever  this is your fault  what did you do to your mom Spencer  you want to play a game with you  ready or not  here we  come  we want to play with you now  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]